what's gwanak just let me just bangla
sorry about that
hello there this video has been very
highly requested throughout the whole
time of slavery guys the Molotov
cocktail yeah now you may not know the
Molotov cocktail was invented by Dave
Molotov in 1921 I was frank Molotov
Frank Molotov yeah Dave and Dave Molotov
invented the frisbee yeah so it's true
no no no that's true but let's do this
anyway how do you feel about throwing a
Molotov cocktail at the place where your
grandparents live it's actually just by
my bedroom edge it's literally just
outside your bedroom yeah what positions
doing they're not really looking forward
to actually yeah I am we're gonna have a
great time yeah dude in your garden it
ah no too small it as a cat there Oh as
a cat yeah can't be lobbing molotovs
when Lloyd the cats walking around right
I'm gonna shoot from behind Dan I want
to see quite Lots it's pretty wide lens
should all be in focus we'll see
exposure is low so we see detail in the
flame there's a plane that's annoyin
don't try this at home because of all
the like face melting and stuff let's go
she's ready yeah
bloody hell it was super effective that
splooge of death
the fireball went up like way up there
then the whole of the ground with them
you should have seen my own if you go to
my face okay it was like oh there's a
show me right the end of the high speed
is good like on fire
that's like action see all right well
obviously don't try that home because
you would be a tip-top what an idiot
would do that to their house it's dead
though what should they do
probably follow us on Twitter Gavin free
Daniel Russia you get sword do you have
a broom yes glass everywhere
that was wicked let's not do that you
know